if you go around taking peace you're gay
you're not i disagree with you i'll go
to bed at six a.m and i'll wake up one
minute before that at 5 59. he's ruder
than tate and you need to be more
misogynistic that's sick
so
you've met andrew tate now did you know
that he had a little brother that is
exactly like him
okay i can't wait i have not seen this
little brother
how little he's also
a couple years younger he's also a
professional kickboxer also has tons of
[ __ ] wow known as the better looking
brother he's the man they
do a ton of crazy [ __ ] together they
share a bank account these two very
interesting stuff okay um also just a
quick reminder to like and subscribe
over 99 of you guys are watching and not
subscribed hit the [ __ ] button now
i'm saying you know what i'm saying i'm
just trying to have a good time you know
what i'm saying there was a romanian man
i spoke to he said something
i was like yeah and you could be like
it's not just getting straight now
there's like 100 different sexualities
and he was confused by it
but there's only three sexualities for
women and two for men i was like two for
men explain so a woman is straight or
gay or bisexual or man is straight okay
is it cat man be bisexual tristan
if you suck dick sometimes
you're gay
i swear to god i've been saying that for
years i feel like i've heard that before
i might have said that because no i know
i've been saying it for years cancel me
but how can you be bi as a guy i don't
know why can't why can't you what's the
difference what's the difference why
can't you you don't take peace and then
just go back to women why not it's what
if you just it's hard for us to
understand because we're not that person
but
if you go around taking peace you're gay
you're not
you're not you know you don't like girls
there's no way i disagree with you most
women experiment with other women if a
guy experiments
most women experiment with others maybe
in your generation you dump on video
games enough in 10 seconds i can i can
very quickly sum this up there's a video
game called grand tourismo where you
select which car you want to drive and
select which road you want to drive and
then you sit in the house of your
mother's basement and pretend to drive
that car on that road i because i've
done the work pick the car i want to
drive because i have all of them and
pick the rotor on the drive and i drive
there and i get to do irl so it's a
substitute for real life that's it fact
same thing with grand theft auto it is
but it's mean not everybody has what
they have what them they didn't it's not
like they were born with what they have
and they're just like they earned they
earned it all they're saying don't sit
around playing video games all day get
off your ass and go earn that stuff i
totally agree with that 100 yes other
people have the same opportunity but
they don't have the same skills brains
intelligence uh you know physical
capabilities like there's that motivates
me whenever i'm playing video games or
some stupid watching some stupid videos
or people living a life that i want to
live i'm like damn i should be doing
something to achieve that not just
sitting around consuming content or
playing video literally totally
everybody could
raise themselves above their stats not
mean that's that's just true i know but
some people are half wits and they're
doing the best they can we need somebody
to cook the fries someone has to cook
the fries dumbass people have their
little bits of happiness in the world so
they have for example uh
a kid a daughter and they have a dog and
they're like oh well you know tristan
you [ __ ] got the millions of dollars
and all the beautiful women in the fast
cars and you're tall and you're strong
and all the women want you but you know
i've got my daughter and my dog money
can't buy that
[ __ ] i've got a daughter and a
dog too and i've got all that [ __ ]
yeah people try to justify having the
little [ __ ] that they have that it i
mean i guess it can make you happy but i
feel like you should always want
want more of life yes people can be
happy with a daughter and a dog but they
they justify the absence of other things
by saying money can't buy happiness
which is totally utter [ __ ] money
can totally buy happiness yeah it's not
gonna bring someone back from the dead
or unbreak a broken heart but it's gonna
i can promise you that our lives have
gotten better since i've made a lot of
money yeah of course it has bought
happiness and it has brought peace of
mind in that whole arena and when you
you are brokenhearted you can go to a
spa and get a massage if you have money
and you can spend time with friends that
you haven't seen in a long time if
there's a social issue that you really
care about enough money can help solve
that yeah you're really sad about the
kids overseas well money can help
[ __ ] give them some meals yeah you
can even go there and and help hands-on
if you can afford to because you can you
know if you don't not work in an hourly
job that you can't i think to take what
really does make people depressed isn't
money it's being born into money and not
having to earn it and and fight your way
up there and not knowing what it's like
to not have money because i remember
times where we were sitting there with
like no money and that [ __ ] sucks it
does but we still had a good time yeah
but looking back
that's that's like he says that's what
that's what makes having money more
enjoyable is remembering the times when
if you wanted to order ubereats you were
really thinking about it you're like oh
should i really spend the twelve dollars
to get this burger now it's like [ __ ] it
yeah i'm hungry yeah you know
why are you asking me that question
why are you on this podcast asking me
how to stop procrastinating turn off
youtube go do something
jesus what's wrong with people this is
exactly what you were talking about
about asking a question we already know
the answer to you know the answer is to
stop doing things that waste your time
and apply yourself to something
important now this may not be a waste of
your time but let me tell you you're a
dumbass clearly it's like googling how
to get fit like you just said everyone
knows what a push-up is do 10 000 of
them a day stop wasting your [ __ ]
time you know i've never had to deal
with procrastination i've never had to
deal with not being motivated because
what is the alternative literally be a
loser forever i am sick of reading [ __ ]
on the internet saying yeah you know
some people are special and they take
longer to bloom and your time will come
let me tell you something 99.9 of people
who are born broke live broke stay broke
die broke that is the reality for almost
everybody the internet and there it's
all gonna come to you at the right time
he's right honestly from me putting my
head down and starting to grind it only
took what maybe seven months before i
hit six figures yeah crazy before that i
was playing fortnite all day trying to
become a professional fortnite player i
said [ __ ] that and i put my head down
watched youtube videos all day made a
bunch of mistakes learned from them read
wrote down my goals read them every day
and seven months later at 18 years old
no complaining no complaining involved
no wasting time there's no there's no
wasting time doing [ __ ] you're
sitting around i couldn't even tell you
the last time i just sat around and
watched netflix that's not something i
that's not even something i do anymore
but you should relax once in a while kid
i need extra sleep after a night out you
are lame i'll go i'll go to bed at six
seconds
so one and start doing push-ups i'll go
to bed at six a.m and i'll wake up one
minute before that at 5 59 minus one
minute sleep that's what i do that's how
i do it so there is no besides night out
my generally early risers i don't need
to sleep for weeks if i don't want to
sleep
he's ruder than tate you think well not
in what he says but in his he's just his
delivery pissed yeah he's just so angry
uh listen he's like 12 years old when
he's 40 he's gonna need a little more
sleep after a night out i don't care how
fit he is he's 34. when was that video
taken i don't know
trust me all right 45 he's gonna need
sleep in the future trust me silly goose
but yes compared to people his age
people who are 25 and tired single no no
husband or wife no kids
just one job and they're like i'm tired
the [ __ ] the matter with you
go home late drink a coffee yeah i have
a cigarette i wasn't tired in my
twenties
you catch your girl on instagram at our
house yeah she says
and she's dancing in the videos she's
dancing she's the dancer police have the
video she's dancing around twerking and
you sit there and go oh my god she's
kidnapped are you okay baby
i'm gonna save you
bro
bro
i'm not just believing that story what
the [ __ ] is wrong with these dudes like
they're killing the story was the
kidnapped the girl yeah
i've been kidnapped before too i get it
what do you mean
just places i shouldn't have been oh
but before the days of where you got
caught on video
yeah they're all over the internet
because i'm a bad boy i'm a bad boy and
you need to be more misogynistic this
woman just spilled my coffee
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bring some paper towels
we're doing a [ __ ] podcast andrew
don't be a misogynist
it's not okay
you know what i i'm jorgin i really want
to apologize for my misogynistic brother
you know i would never say anything like
that because i have a paper i am a
gentleman damn straight i'm joking
they're just kidding you know what you
know what you know what i like about
that that's obviously we're just
laughing about that but there i would
love to just
i don't have any super woke friends
because i can't tolerate it but i would
love to just see some super
the [ __ ] girl like
that who has zero sense of humor lose
her you look at that video like the tick
tock comments in that video and you're
like these people are [ __ ] droids how
well
you look at comments and you're like all
right now i understand that there's
always people to cook the fries just
that's when yeah just imagine having no
sense of humor whatsoever no that's
that's a that's a funny joke
it's funny it's stupid it's funny
yesterday was my birthday he has better
look and then
all my birthday yeah he's considered the
better i did kfc because when i was 21
me and andrew used to have no food i
used to drive to the kfc restaurant and
i used to sit in my car and you couldn't
ever eat anyone's leftover food if they
ever had their mouth on it but at kfc
they used to buy buckets and i would sit
and wait for people to stay outside eat
their meal and leave the bucket on the
table and i used to go and take that
bucket three or four pieces
broken
wow no i'm joking that's sad it's a
chicken and i still have 20 30 40 pieces
of chicken
20 30 40 pieces of chicken wait ty i
want to know the rest what then we used
to go home and i used to freeze that
chicken i mean andrew would break it up
put it in our rice and that was our meal
that's what sustained us for that hard
year that year we had when i was 21 and
you were 22. that's how broke we were i
used to scavenge chicken from kfc
because i thought [ __ ] i'm not dying and
i'm losing my kickboxing fights because
i don't have enough protein that's how
broke i was and that's a sad story if
you never make it out to me that's a
happy story that's a story of triumph
now say hey andrew's my birthday what we
doing kfc and it's a big joke we sit
there read our kfc laughing about how we
used to scavenge kfc chicken that's like
that really is the beauty in making
money is remembering
the stories and times that you didn't
have it
yeah and making you know making more of
yourself being successful not just it's
not just about the money it's about who
you become in the process of creating
wealth for your family and as long as
you can still be a good person and have
integrity and be kind for me those are
those the measures that matter if you
can stay humble
humility you know was lost on these guys
but they did have the successful part
where they said do you think that
there's a difference between being
humble and having an ego don't you think
it's healthy to have an ego
and like force yourself to live up to
that ego because i'd like to say i'm
humble like if anyone dms me i always
help them out i'm you know
like i like to help people and you know
i'm not like a dick to random people but
i also acknowledge and i talk
confidently like damn like i am the man
like three videos in the youtube and i'm
out two hundred fifty thousand views
like yeah that makes me wanna [ __ ]
level man that's like that's the way i
think right that makes me wanna like hit
you in the back of the head because i'm
young because you're teaching other
people it's showing credibility and i'm
also starting an online university so i
need people you need you need your
credibility you need to have the little
dragon but you know but
inside though inside i really
i will make sure that you don't become
arrogant i will ruin your life
i will i will i'll ruin you yeah because
my goal is like i want to you know i
want my results and stuff to speak for
themselves i don't want people to have
to question if i'm being legit or not at
this point i feel like it does no you
need credibility i get what you're
saying but just don't be an arrogant
[ __ ] like there's there's a line
doesn't mean you can't say i
accomplished abc
it just means you can't i feel like i'm
not an [ __ ] i'm just confident about
it i'm just gonna i'm gonna let you know
when you cross the line okay
we have 27 cars between us and we drive
them whenever we want yes they're all on
our drive they're all ours yes the house
is ours yes it's all ours besides women
and underwear we share everything yeah
so some loser said to me famously on uh
the comment blew up he said you and your
brother sharing uh sharing one car i
said no no we share 27 cars uh six
mansions and 100 million dollars
that's crazy though they literally share
a bank account that's nice i can see
doing that though it's i think it's
really sweet i wish i had a brother that
i had that closer relationship with you
got a mother yeah i don't trust you
though you're gonna go spend money on
dumb [ __ ] like like a dumb
joke
but i i will buy land and dogs yes yeah
we're gonna have i'm gonna come home and
there's gonna be 20 dogs i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on no the answer is no
i'm on loads of testosterone you know
what boost testosterone by 15
smoking
it really does i don't need injections
we don't take steroids ever i put my
blood test on twitter and i'll do
another blood test here live and put it
on live we do not take drugs stop asking
stupid questions never taken
testosterone i don't take creatine
protein shake none of that crap you know
what i do i smoke cigars i drink foods i
have threesomes and i hit the gym
that's it and i lift weights like a g
that's hilarious they've never done
drugs or anything in their lives because
since they were 18 years old they
couldn't take drugs or anything so for
like the next 10 years while they were
fighting and they couldn't take drugs
they got so far they were just like well
screw it i haven't smoked weed
right now why start i'm just stick to it
it's pretty cool when they retire doubt
it there is a way to get revenge on
women say goodbye politely i love this
working hard increase your value as a
man wait three years four years 11 years
wait till you are the man and she's just
now some chick 28 29 yeah she's like
tristan you know it should have always
been you then you can either tell her no
or break your heart again then you win
that's the only way to get revenge yeah
you're gonna keep working on yourself
and keep working on yourself yeah no
thank you
that's what i love that's what i do same
for women that's what i love though just
keep working on yourself until oh she
just regrets it i feed off of knowing
people regret what they did to me
and knowing that i'm doing better than
other people
i just feed off of that i'm like i come
in i come onto youtube and i'm doing
better than this dudes i've been posting
forever i'm just like
oh rachel i used to feel that way and
now i'm like so far comfortable in such
a comfort level in my skin that i just
don't even give a [ __ ] i like like
helping other people though too because
then it also increases your
competitiveness and makes you want to do
better than them even while helping them
because i have friends who i help out
with tick tock like my friend gabe he's
killing it right now he's like 70 000
followers three and a half million views
and i'm like so proud of him but i still
i'm like i want to do [ __ ] better
than you and he's do he's killing it
right now so that's and i want to keep
that
uh competition that's not revenge
mindset yeah and it's not like i would
ever do anything to hurt him it's just
like damn like i always want to be the
best yeah that's just that's just that
but like as far as revenge goes like i
said i used to care about that and now i
just i truly don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody thinks anybody that's hurt me in
the past i'm like carry on i don't care
oh you're doing great you're doing
shitty i mean it is a little more fun if
they're doing shitty but like if they're
you know just for amusement's sake but i
really do it doesn't drive or affect me
at all is it fun when you'd like date a
girl i'm not you date a girl when you
date a guy and then he goes and the next
girl's uglier than you do girls like
that because i love that [ __ ] when i'm
talking to a girl and then the next
dude's like some little dweeb and ugh
and uglier oh my gosh
i don't confirm myself to other women
okay i i don't i think it's hilarious
your hands
are controlled by your brain if you
can't stop [ __ ] drinking jerking off
watching porn and typing pornhub into
your little keyboard
that is nobody's fault but your
assistance thing is weak will
your hands are controlled by your brain
use your brain and control your [ __ ]
hands
i think this is a silly video he's like
trying to be deep it's like just
control your brain is the real point is
it just youtube is there more siblings
is there more teeth i have a sister who
doesn't talk to me lives in america you
know full left-wing blm crazy
things that i exploit women because of
my business even though i have women who
work for me who make more than she does
even though she's a lawyer
i wonder what that sister thinks now
with how famous they are like literally
two of some of the most famous people in
the world if she's truly woke she thinks
they're disgusting if she's like
actually like yeah like he explains yeah
she must hate them anybody on the left
hates them because they hate the idea of
a patriarchy and men having like they
hate the idea of gender roles they can't
they can't really comprehend that so
they must just despise them
but you know a lot of what they're
saying
is especially true in the part of the
world where they are it sounds like the
women that are in their sphere are doing
better than all the women all the other
women in that part of the world that in
their you know in their social circles
so oh yeah they're actually the girls
that worked for them were making a
killing they're actually raising these
women above what they would be doing in
romania outside of this probably sounds
like what's luke's usual bed time
5 p.m 5 p.m 5 p.m because he's a little
sleepy
well these
it's an amazing american potion that
i've discovered had four already
so if i drink my fifth one then i'll be
up for 25 hours
[Music]
so delicious have you tried those
yeah are they good red bulls i mean um
five hour energy yeah yeah when me and
my friends were little and we'd go to
john paul's house we'd play video games
till like six in the morning and we'd
take those to stay awake we're like 12
and 13 and we'd have to i don't know i
don't even know if we
back then we might have just stolen them
from 7-eleven because
that's enough that's enough
we were evil all right listen i we were
evil little kids i'm not gonna you know
that
nah that has no followers and it's
private that each time i sleep with a
new woman starting at this year i just
i'll put a picture of her for myself
[Laughter]
that's so funny that's sick that's like
a
that's some top g [ __ ] right there i
used to have a little black book oh i
don't see them that wasn't necessarily
there to slap in somebody who don't be
like that but just like guys i dated and
i had a key of like to open the book i
had it no
there was like a key i would put there
was like a little drawing
they'd have little drawings next to them
and it was the guys
like there would be a knife or a you
know like a z if they were
girls nowadays just have all the dudes
in their notes tab yeah if you're
talking to a girl and you want to know
if she's a hoe or not look through her
notes i have to see if i can have that
little black book somewhere i'll show
you that'd be funny maybe there's some
stories in there someone said eve
genuinely believe he just exaggerates
for the camera no no i live with him
this is just how he is this is how i am
this is just how it is
so um
what is that
why are you thumbs up for me unless i'm
something you [ __ ]
no self-awareness that they're going to
be 60 one day sitting at that same table
they're going to be g's with when
they're 60. dude they look pretty good
for their age right now you can't even
lie only for their age they're little
babies he's 35 you think that's a baby
yes you're tripping it's an old man
you're tripping
last year and i was catching up with a
few friends the guy i used to know i
won't say his name he looked me straight
in the eye we were talking about when we
were 17 18 and used to
he looked me straight in the eye he was
overweight the spark in his eye had left
him he looked at me goes you know those
are the best days of my life and i
thought isn't that tragic you're not 14
years separated from when we were just
discovering how to be men you was
discovering this world and you look back
as though those were the best days of
your life you broke my heart
that's a lot of people's story i know
that's that's what makes that's what
makes me especially sad because i see a
lot of people who spend their entire
life living in this town and you know
your friends and stuff that you know are
never going to leave and it kind of
makes you sad well i don't think you
have to leave to to have a wonderful
life i really don't i just think i i
just think you have to keep creating a
life that makes you fulfilled and happy
and and you know you can't have you
can't live your whole life going to high
school or when i was 18 or you know
freshman year of college was the best
year of my life i look back at freshman
year of college i'm like that was so
much fun that was a blast oh my god
freshman year of college i'm still
having a blast though like my life is
still fun because i haven't just given
up and thrown in the towel and that
makes me sad when somebody's like that
i'm like why have you thrown in the
towel what are you doing
no yeah 100 i'm saying it's just me it
is sad it is sad like i'm so excited for
my future like moving down to miami
doing all like having a whole new
experience but looking back on the first
semester of school before i started my
businesses and i was just making content
and enjoying time with my new friends it
was like the best and going going to an
all boys high school and then going to a
school in florida that was fun yeah life
can always be fun it doesn't like when
you hit 25 35 45 55 like it doesn't have
to get dull no
it's and that's just for somebody who's
like just just going through the motions
every day and waking up [ __ ] that [ __ ]
man [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that nine to
five stuff that sucks i would kill i
hate the thought of even doing that i
can't believe i used to go throughout my
day thinking i can't wait for saturday
and sunday those are like the only days
i can be happy that literally repulses
me that's that's how i used to think
remember when i used to work in
advertising and i did all that and i
paid the bills and i did what i had to
do but
every morning and you probably didn't
even know this when my alarm went off
every single morning i went [ __ ] every
morning and it was a [ __ ] way to start
that's a terrible way to live
and you know and i did have so much fun
in other ways with family and friends
but it was it was the the meat of my
life or the most waking hours was spent
at that job that was just terrible [ __ ]
that [ __ ] i can't people who say that
they're that they're like okay with the
nine to five are literally lying to you
you are not okay with the nine to five
how could you possibly be okay with a
nine to five go into a job they're oh
they're okay with it they're okay with
it it's fine they they're just like it's
fine i'm doing what i got to do for my
family they're justifying it they've got
and you do have to take care of your
family you forget it's just justifying
it but you forget like people
not everybody's creative not everybody
has guts not everybody is ready to go
out and chase a dream when they've got a
mortgage and two kids and all this [ __ ]
it's hard but you know you're you're an
exception that you're doing it when
you're 18. i just don't understand it
like i can't wrap my mind well i hope
you never get stuck in that trap i would
i would never that's not even an option
i already know now that i'll never have
a real job for the rest of my life all
right i hope you're right i know for a
fact i won't either i know you're right
i won't either you because you're so
driven and entrepreneurial me because i
just i'm done taking orders from anybody
everybody can go to hell [ __ ] sucks
we're gonna be [ __ ] youtubers type
[ __ ] no i'm saying
i'm having so much fun with you though
right now it's such a blast someone told
me that i could make an extra one
million dollars a month for 20 minutes a
day of extra work i would say no i don't
need the million dollars i like those 20
minutes you can get head in 20 minutes
you can chill by the pool in 20 minutes
you can do lots of things in 20 minutes
i'm not interested in extra work for
what a million dollars
[ __ ] brokey
money okay
i i would like to just for the record
say i fully disagree and if i could make
one million dollars in 20 minutes
they're lying out of their eyes they're
worth 100 million dollars if it's 20
million if it's
20 minutes you're doing it it's
obviously a joke three months you double
your you double your worth yeah think
about the family members we could pay
you could pay off everybody's mortgage
we could help all those dogs that dog
rescue that i that i donate to every
month we can just give them millions of
dollars and save all the dogs yeah
that'd be nice it'll be nice and and and
that um that other tunnels to towers
i like that or you just pay a bunch of
[ __ ] to hang out with you
nope
that works too no pay everybody to stay
the [ __ ] away people ask me today why i
wear a watch that's worth no more than
maybe a grand if i tried to sell it
secondhand brand new you could buy
something equivalent for about two and a
half it's a versace watch gold plated i
don't have a rolex i don't have a hublot
i don't actually own another watch
swatch doesn't even tell the time it is
broken it has been 20 minutes past 11
for the last god knows how long it's the
middle of the afternoon i wear this
watch because it is a reminder
of the indomitable spirit of man my
brother went to slovakia we were both in
slovakia but i came home one day before
because my holiday pay had run out and i
had to go to work
so he calls me and said something
amazing has happened i want some money
in the casino i'm like really how much 5
000 euros [ __ ] good we need to pay
the rent we got these payments to make
on the car insurance and we need the
money good take that five thousand euro
don't go back to the casino he comes
home i said where's the cash he goes i
don't have any cash i bought this watch
this watch cost what back then
eleven years ago probably four thousand
something euros he spent it all on this
[ __ ] function
and it wasn't an argument as such but i
was pissed you know i'm like we need to
pay the rent we need to pay this how can
you just spend it on a watch what's that
what's going to do for you and you said
to me
we'll we'll make more money don't worry
we'll make more money so we had our
little argument you know and got on with
life and i completely forgot about that
small falling out until about six years
ago i was 24 you were 25
and we we had indeed made more money we
were walking to westfield shopping
center and you bought your hublot watch
when you saw it for sale it was 12 900
british pounds
and you said i like that watch i said
okay go get the watch you walk through
the shop you use the card you get the
watch and then you take this one off and
you give it to me i like that i like
that story a lot you know sometimes i
get stressed out when i'm spending a lot
of money on
investing into myself like hiring people
to create seconds of my course or hiring
editors to do really good quality work
for me and i'm like damn i'm spending a
lot of [ __ ] money right now but i'm
like you know what i'm gonna make more
money at the end of the day it's not the
end of the world yeah you can't just
hoard it all you gotta you gotta invest
in yourself like what else is the point
of it what am i gonna buy a stock hope
it goes up eight percent oh my god i'm
not paying percentage yes yes you have
to find balance when the rent's not paid
you got to pay the rent yes
i know i've been there too where i'm
like i i send clients thank you gifts
and i'm like yeah you know
just could go to this or go to that or
just leave it there and let it sit but
i'm like i know this is going to come
back i know that where there's more
money coming in and so i i think that
being generous and being you know
putting the money out there and letting
it flow is one thing but when you've
when you have no money and you haven't
paid the rent and you buy a watch you're
just an [ __ ] that's that's [ __ ]
insane like that is genuinely insane
that's genuinely stupid yeah no that's
where tate is like that's where i don't
really understand but like wow you do
some crazy [ __ ] it is a cool story
because it worked out for them but what
if it didn't what if it was like he
spent and then we got kicked out and we
lived in a tent with six women yeah
you know like come on you watched this
far you might as well hit the [ __ ]
bell
subscribe follow the social medias join
the discord it's going to change your
life
thanks for coming thanks all right this
was fun good night all right love you
guys
peace
[Music]